muss wirklich Sel her der war
Kind ist definitiv nicht besser
worden sag wann kommt dein neuer Freund
noch mal erst in guten halben Stunde
super Biss sportteilen was macht gleich
noch mal beruflich auch nichts
Besonderes Sanitär und Heizungstechniker
was
Handwerker ja ich glaub schon GI ein
handwer und Heizung das macht doch ein
Handwerker oder ja Handwerker Bingo und
dann Gaswasser scheiße das hat er glaube
ich nicht so gern ja zu S ich ja nicht
dis ja was ist denn ja kriegst du das
nicht mit unser Corina hat ein
Handwerker an der Angel nicht so Deerten
Philosophie Studenten wir sonst immer
richtigen Handwerker Gas Wasser Scheiße
ja wo hast denn den kennengelernt WE
schon kennengelernt haben beim
scheißhäuselräum was Quatsch er ist mit
einem aus meiner WG befreundet ach so
und da hat scheiusel Herrschaft nein er
war einfach zu Besuch da ist ja
vollkommen wurscht jedenfalls ist dieser
secher ist es mit Zusatzzahl mit
Superzahl und
prämienziehung oh Gottes will der hat
sofort dieses Ikea GRA Weg mener und das
silbergesteck und Gottes W sofort bitte
den staubigen sandker Weg ich gehe jetzt
g über zum feink chefer und H eine
kirschmaskpon
stapeltorte geld spielt
Rolle und und und mir legst den
italienischen Anzug legst mal raus was
geh da passt du doch mal ne der muss
passen und wenn ich den ganzen Tag nicht
atme und und und du z K schwarze das Mus
beim Onkel Hermann seiner dritten
Hochzeit gehabt hast was das teure Teil
du sag findest das nicht ein bisschen
übertrieben übertrieben übertrieben
jetzt kommt der Handwerker ein
Handwerk Gas Waser scheiße das wenn du
einmal zu ihm sagst schau ja aus wie
Idiot sag nichts und du Zst auch was
anderses an was wieso was denn ja
vielleicht einfach
weniger ja los
los Handwerker komm Handwerker h gar
nicht zrau na ja man muss ja da einmal
Glück haben im Leben du vergisst die
Torte feilich gell los jetzt ah
[Musik]
Fall so noch Hände
waschen oh
Gott Gas Waser
Scheiße ZTE mit das GE
se will fleißige Hand
[Applaus]
[Musik]
se